في امريكا ولايه بيلا وير هي
الاسكورب هي اكثر استخداما في العالم
واكثر من يعني يرغب فيها الصناديق
الراسماليه في امريكا وهي يعني
نستخدمها كثيرا
في في الشرق
ونقسم في اوروبا لكن نحن في في صدره يعني
تحسين قوانيننا المحليه
كل يوم تطويرها محليه نعم وهذا بيجعلنا
نتساءل عن انه هناك تقارير تتحدث عن بلوغ
سوق الامريكيه مرحله الاشباع الى اي حد
توافق على ذلك وليست هذه فرصه للتوجه
والتركيز على الاسواق العربيه الاسواق
المحليه اما ان هناك يعني ظروف تمنع من
ذلك
انا يعني
كشخص في عالم الاستثمار ياتي مصطلح يعني
رئاسه اللوكيشن او توزيع الاصول المستثمر
الذكي يعني لا تضع يعني في سله واحده حتى
في الاسواق الامريكيه وزع
وبعد الالوكيشن للسوق الامريكي انظر الى
سوقك هنا سوق المحلي في الاسهم فنحن جزء
من الاسد راس المال الجريء فانظر الى
الصناديق
يعني لا انظر الى تشبع انظر اليها توزيع
اصول والمستثمر الذكي ما بتعرفي ممكن يكون
سوق يعني في مرحله ضعف يغطي عليه السوق
الاخر ممكن
نوع من الضعف انا
بجيب العائد اللي اطلبه من البنشر كافر
يعني الكثير من المستثمرين المحليين
ينظروا الى صندوق نما لتوزيع فيه عالم
الهايروس طبعا صحيح نستثمر في اوائل مرحله
الشركات التقييم الناشئه لكن انضربت تغطي
على يعني معظم العائد
لتجنيه من استثمارك في القابلك فهي يعني
توزيع اصول براي وبتعمل توازن يعني خساره
من جهه وربح من جهه اخرى بس هناك شركات
ناشئه يعني اذا صح السؤال توظف عدد قليل
من
الموظفين وهذه الشركات
الناشئه
مثل ابل مثل غيرها هي عدد قليل من
الموظفين بعكس شركات اخرى توظف الالاف من
العاملين لديهم ما الفرق بينهما
والله سؤال صعب ولكن يعني الجواب مصطلحين
ياتوا في في بالي
التوسع والكفاءه يعني انت ذكرتي بعض
الشركات
ابل على هذا التليفون هو تليفون
ومكتبك للعمل وكاميرا وجهازك الموسيقي
وهناك كفاءه عاليه تقدمها الشركات التقنيه
لا تستطيع الشركات التقليديه
يعني اكبر شركه
اوتيلات في العالم لا تمتلك فندق واحد
اكبر شركه تاكسي في العالم اوبر لا تمتلك
سياره واحده
فاسكيل اللي تراه
في الشركات
التقنيه لا يعني مستحيل ان ترى مرادف لها
في الشركات التقليديه هذا هذا الكود اللي
في هذا التطبيقات يخدم عشره يخدم مئه يخدم
الف يخدم مئه مليون شركات تقليديه محكومه
هذا برايي الفرق